I'm going to stop saying the word sperm
and bring on Cabot Phillips Cabot why
are we talking about this because I went
to you during lunch yesterday and said
Michael we need to talk about sperm on
your show tomorrow and you said uh all
right okay I guess
Michael we're talking about this because
there actually is a crisis of
infertility that is looming right now
globally so go back to 2017 there was a
team of European researchers who
published this very controversial study
claiming that sperm counts had dropped
50 in men since the year 1970 they were
panned by a group of influential
researchers at Harvard who came out and
said well this data this data is
cherry-picked it's fear-mongering you
don't look at men in other parts of the
world only in European and America and
you're and uh you know American men only
these Western countries you didn't look
at the whole world nothing to see here
so this team of researchers said okay
we'll conduct the largest meta-analysis
ever on sperm counts look at over 200
studies since 1970 get this published in
the human reproduction update Journal
very renowned medical journal and they
found that the problem was actually even
worse than they thought since 1970
Michael there's been a 62 percent
decrease in the average male sperm count
globally taking into account Africa
Latin America South America country
initially that had been left out a 62
percent decrease in sperm count so back
in the 1970s the average man had over
100 million sperm per milliliter of
semen now we know that the average man
is at 49 million per milliliter doctors
say that anything in the 40 to 50
million uh range is cause for concern
with fertility and that each decrease
once you get below 50 each decrease of 5
million starts to Compound on itself and
will cause serious fertility issues the
average decrease so far has been one to
two percent per year you could do the
math on on where this is going so it's
not just that it was a sudden drop it's
a steady drop a steady drop there was an
increase in the drop starting in the
year 2000 there had been about a one to
a point eight percent drop in the late
90s and it accelerated to a one to two
percent drop starting in the year 2000.
so what is causing there are two main
theories right now from researchers one
has to do with Lifestyle the other has
to do with with chemicals that are in
our environment as well as things
happening to women when they are
pregnant with children so we'll start
with the lifestyle element there are a
few things that we do know that cause
testosterone levels to drop and lower
testosterone does equal lower sperm
count so among those things inactivity
obviously we know that a lot more people
are inactive these days lack of exposure
to sunlight can cause vitamin D
deficiencies that causes your
testosterone to drop but there are other
things as well porn addiction plays a
role in testosterone levels dropping and
obviously there's an epidemic of men
addicted to porn that's causing their
sperm counts to drop but also the big
one Beyond alcohol and drug use that
plays a role as well the big one here is
obesity so we know without a shadow of a
doubt that obesity causes testosterone
levels and sperm counts to drop since
1970 we've seen a tripling of obesity
rates in most developed countries and so
that is scary but at the same time some
of those are reversible Trends so there
was a Danish study back in 2019 for
example that took a group of obese men
they put them on a strict eight-week
low-calorie diet the men who are able to
lose over 30 pounds during that eight
week diet so their sperm counts go up 41
on average in that time frame so there
are things you can do to get your
testosterone levels up get sperm counts
going in the right direction but the
other part of this is exposure to
chemicals and that's a lot harder to
reverse well it's funny you mention it
because I was half jokingly going to
blame it all on seed oils as I have
mentioned to the Daily wire member block
I have never gotten behind any fad diet
nutrition stuff my whole life
other than the seed oil thing I am
totally convinced seed oils poison made
by the devil they they might be
constitutive of the Devil Himself okay
and so got to avoid the seed oils but I
said I don't know is there any way but
one of the arguments about the seed oils
is it causes people to become obese it
causes inflammation it causes all this
so it actually in an indirect way might
have something to do with this sperm
issue yes it pains me to say but Michael
you were right on that I do think of a
lot of people they hear some of these
phrases like forever chemicals and bpas
and microplastics and Seed oils and it's
easy to Discount and say oh this is some
hippie garbage or because the
environmental movement has pushed so
much you know fear-mongering and kind of
pseudoscience to try and get their
agenda passed that it's easy to Discount
a lot of these things there is a growing
body of really indisputable evidence
that these forever chemicals that are
being produced and that are building up
in people's bodies microplastic bpas the
the negative impacts of seed oils and
things of that nature are having a
direct impact on the uh on on human
hormone production it messes up your
endocrine system which has plays a huge
role in your fertility and so now there
is a growing body of evidence that take
for example these forever chemicals
which are found in all sorts of plastics
and a lot of uh you know home grooming
products and candles and and scents
um but also a big thing you know
non-stick pans a lot of people are
becoming more aware of that there was a
study that was conducted back in 2020
looked at women who were pregnant that
had been exposed to Forever chemicals
through non-stick pans and that had
higher levels of forever chemicals in
their water supply compared to women who
lived in more rural areas that were not
exposed to them they found that there
was a direct correlation of the sons of
those pregnant women in penis size get
this I'm going to look up the exact I
want to make sure I get this right the
men whose mothers while pregnant were
exposed to Forever chemicals 11.5
percent smaller penises than those who
were not exposed and there's a direct
correlation there with testosterone in
in utero and so not only is it impact in
testosterone I think a lot of men perk
up when they hear wait a second these
forever chemicals can can impact my
manhood in that way as well you know I
don't want to tell any Tales out of
school but when sweet little Elisa was
pregnant with our eldest son we go in
and you know Elise is crazy about not no
non-stick no plastics no she's really
gone super hippie on all this stuff and
we go in and she's having the ultrasound
and the doctor says okay and now we I I
could tell you the sex of your child if
you want do you want to know and we said
yes yes she goes uh your child is a boy
and he's very clearly a boy I said my my
boy my son all right well this is now I
have to thank the lack of non-stick pans
that actually is something I'm not going
to comment on on your unborn child's
endowment appreciate that not going to
talk about that yeah but I will say that
there is a growing body of evidence that
this stuff is legit again I I don't
think that this is something that we can
just write off now and say oh it's all
out there it's all hippie so there are
things though that you can do to start
to reverse this um doctors do encourage
people to start using more glass
containers because the hard plastic
especially it's hard plastic containers
Tupperware things like that do play a
role especially when they're heated in
in releasing many of these chemicals
into which we always do I mean the point
of Tupperware is you throw it in the
microwave and then it has effects that
sound very scary as you're not great so
go get glass for those things and and uh
the other part that they encourage
people to do is just physical activity
because again the clearest correlation
here as well is obesity and impact in
this but Michael I think you got to look
at this big picture as well because of
the fact that it's not just sperm count
that is going to impact fertility rates
it's also the personal choices of women
we know beyond a you know any any
question right now that women are
waiting longer than ever before to start
having children into want to have
children and because birth rates have
declined and you know virtually every
single industrialized Western Country at
this point the window for which women
have a chance to get pregnant is getting
smaller because they're waiting for
their late 20s early 30s on average now
right and when you combine that that
shorter window with less motility from
Men the odds of having as many children
as you might want to have or always
imagine having as a younger woman do go
down and so that's another Factor here
that's going to start to impact birth
rates if we don't reverse this trend
right because it's not just that you
know the the male fertility is a little
bit lower because the sperm counts have
decreased it's also this combination of
factors really compounds on itself so
you add on to that trying at a later
stage you add on to that all of these
chemicals you add on to that obesity you
add on to all of these things all of a
sudden your chances of becoming pregnant
have dropped dramatically exactly and
that's kind of the thing that doctors
are warning of is hey you can do some
things that you can fix in in your own
lifestyle to start to you know increase
your chances but some of this you know
as sad as it is is out of your control
so much of this matters with what
happens to you in utero and early
development the other thing they were
pointing out too pregnant women there
was a direct correlation between uh they
there was another study where they
looked at women and the number of
prescription medications they were on
during their pregnancy and there were a
lot of medicines that we kind of think
of as harmless acetaminophen was one
pregnant women taking acetaminophen on a
regular basis there was a direct
correlation there with their sons they
followed them up until adolescence
through puberty and found a direct
correlation there with young children
exposed to acetaminophen in the womb
with a direct correlation of them having
negative Health impacts including lower
testosterone levels and lower sperm
count there so there's all sorts of
things right now that that doctors are
discovering hey maybe this stuff is not
great for Humanity as a species maybe
when you start looking into uh what's
going to lead to us uh you know
continuing to have children in the
future but this this is scary stuff it's
easy to laugh off I do appreciate you
giving platform to me to talk about this
because it is serious we got to get more
people talking about this more people
having kids I'm going to go home and you
know I'm ready to have a baby we've been
married two and a half years let's do it
all right and listen Kevin this isn't
this kind of show you know I mean this
is no we don't need to get graphic
details but you're right we need to get
more people talking about it because we
need to get more people so they got to
cut out the porn they gotta cut out the
poison pill popping they gotta cut out
the weird plastic stuff everywhere they
got to cut out all the gross chemicals
in the foods and they gotta go and be
fruitful and multiply Cabot thank you
for coming on the show and clearing this
up I'm Michael Knowles this is Michael
Knowles show we'll see you tomorrow
foreign